I don't think this video needs an
introduction so first at the very bottom
this should come as absolutely no
surprise we have the Battle of
Winterfell it's hilarious that the epic
climactic battle of the entire series
both has terrible and Visually
disgusting action and a story with
abhorent usage of plot armor in every
single nanc of screen time I could
really go off and rail into the story in
depth about why it's so bad but I'll
primarily touch on the action since I've
covered most story issues a lot in past
videos now the first main thing that's
been brought up a lot is the visibility
of the action I understand the creators
wanted to creatively show the long night
as being very dark but you have to keep
the audience in mind there are certain
mechanics within storytelling like
unrealistic lighting that viewers
naturally accept as long as it aids the
viewing experience on a technicality if
you were to shoot in these conditions
then yes it would be pitch black but
that's not how movies and shows operate
non-tic lighting which is lighting that
doesn't have a physical Source within
the in the world has become very
commonplace and thus viewers have become
used to it so in dark environments when
you don't supply enough non-tic lighting
it's even worse because it shatters the
norm of lighting dark settings not to
mention there being a lot of fog and
smoke that makes things even harder to
see so that's the visibility side of
things which still feels a bit rough
even with the extra lighting later on
then we have the action side of things
to me what makes action so entertaining
is complex and great choreography that
shows off the imense skill of the
character at hand in the Battle of
Winterfell there's only like two scenes
in the entire episode that have long
form choreography almost everything is
just quick cut action where we only
Linger on a character for a few seconds
as they cut through a couple whites in
small doses this is fine so that you can
instill a sense of chaos but when most
of the action is like this it becomes
very tiring in large scale battle
sequences you need to follow a given
character for a decent amount of time so
that the action is more comprehensible
we can view the action from one
continuing perspective instead of
quickly trying to cover every single
base lots of large- scale action set
pieces do this and an example I'll use
is Helms Deep since the creators already
compared this battle to that one which
is pretty sad you follow each given hero
for a good chunk of time as they're met
with certain obstacles that they have to
overcome this gives the action more
depth and allows the audience to become
more attached to the moment as they
adore the brilliant choreography however
in the Battle of Winterfell the only two
character that got this were Ari on the
wall and Jon snows want her to get to
bran there are other small moments but
the battle feels more like they put an
emphasis on quantity of moments over
quality moments I think a perfect
opportunity to have more choreography
would have been what the white walkers
entering Winterfell because they have to
go through the courtyard which is where
most of our characters are located so
having a fight between some of them at
least would have been a major help to
the overall action quality instead of
them being pinned against the wall
perpetually surrounding Ed by whites
where they should have died a dozen
times so even the presentation of the
action destroys any suspension of
disbelief because they are always in
scenarios where they should have died so
overall those major action issues with
other story issues like the brainless
dothi charge the terrible defensive
layout putting the triet in the middle
of your army with no additional trenches
and the death of the night King makes
this my least favorite battle in Game of
Thrones which is really depressing I
love to do a scene by scene breakdown
and go into all the numerous issues I
didn't have time to dive into but we
need to get going second from the bottom
we have the fall of King's Landing now
the special effects in the spectacle
within this battle are honestly pretty
great it's really just the story that
absolutely craters what chances of
enjoyment I would have had within this
battle sequence because if the story
wasn't completely brain dead then I'd
probably really enjoy this battle
however that isn't the case and the
massive elephant in the room is Danny's
turn I've already explained in many
videos about why her Arc was butchered
here the most recent one being the top
10 most ruined characters so I don't
want to spend a lot of time going over
that again outside of Danny's Arc
there's your usual flare of contrived
writing and plot armor the contrived
aspect that really drives me up a wall
whenever I watched this episode is the
fact that the Scorpions turn into
incompetent weapons being manned by
people who are mentally AFK and I'm not
talking about Danny destroying the fleet
which is a whole other issue since there
are like a 100 ships and she could
barely handle less than a dozen the
episode before but the entire City's
defenses not even moving to shoot at her
is unacceptable when previously in the
story you make it to where a man
scorpion has the range and accuracy of a
worldclass sniper you then can't make
them comically ineffective it just
screams contrived then there's the other
dumb points like Arya dying multiple
times and you're on teleporting to ja's
exact position in space and time so it's
not just a n snapping which is what a
lot of people assume what's wrong with
this battle instead it's a constant
stream stream of dumb writing beats that
SN this battle lower and lower then I
said the spectacle was pretty great but
the action within the spectacle is
really nothing special and it's at times
pretty bad like the fight between Jamie
and euron is flat out jarring and even
has a moment that breaks continuity on
top of there not really being any other
fight scenes besides the mountain versus
the hound which is really the only
saving grace of the battle sequence so
in essence there may be some gorgeous
spectacle within this battle that can
wow you but it feels weightless because
of how much it's robbed by the writing
at number eight we have the siege of
marine initially I wasn't even thinking
about counting this as a battle because
of how fast and anticlimactic it was but
it technically counts it's pretty crazy
that this battle is smooshed into the
battle of the bastards episode like you
can really tell how fast David and Dan
are rushing to try and resolve
everything in Marine so that Danny can
head to Westeros if anything it feels
like this battle should have had at
least half of an episode on its own
because it's literally the the climax of
a plot line that lasted almost three
seasons let that sink in David and Dan
resolved the major climactic point in
less than 10 minutes this is probably
the biggest example of rushing along the
story now from a technical standpoint
Danny can easily smash the Masters
because she has dragons and two separate
large armies so you may be thinking well
Super Cuts Del light the battle is so
fast because Daenerys made Slight Work
of taking out the Masters but why the
hell would the Masters do this then they
yielding magnificent results by just
using the sons of the harpy to cause
Mass unrest within Marine L tyon
genuinely didn't know how to stop what
was happening as you can see in the
beginning of season 6 Marine is
basically a ghost town entrenched in
misery and fear the second the masters
withd draw the sons of the harpy Marine
instantly explodes with life and social
Prosperity so the question stands in
that why would the Masters not continue
doing this and watch the city slowly die
and wither away especially since they
know that that Daenerys will be leaving
to westero soon which is also confusing
as to why they destroyed her Fleet and
instead they decide to use the sons of
the harpy who are just regular people
with no fighting experience as a full
force Army to take over the city so
David and Dan are essentially Jerry
riging the story into a nonsensical
Direction so that it can quickly end and
Danny can move on without any burdens
because unsurprisingly the sons of the
harpy are quickly snuffed out by Danny's
Army and she uses her dragons to
instantly make them surrender watching
her torch a ship with her three dragons
is a satisfying moment with some payoff
but that's really the only positive
aspect of this entire sequence the only
reason why I wouldn't put this lower in
the battle ranking is because the
writing doesn't infuriate me as much as
the Battle of Winterfell and the fall of
King's Landing it's just here and
blending into the corner as you forget
about it since the battle of the
bastards is much more memorable and
overshadows it completely for number
seven we have the iron Fleet surprise
attack this is again another small
battle that that I would count because
of its large scale and it's an actual
scene unlike the assault on casterly
Rock which is kind of just a montage the
main reason that I'm putting this battle
low on this list is because it's really
short and there aren't a ton of
impressive aspects about it it's mostly
generic quick cut action which gets the
job done then there's one satisfying
choreograph scene where yuron kills the
sand snakes this feels kind of
fanservicey because of the fan hatred
towards them but it was still good
nonetheless in particular I like the
variety in weapon combat in terms of
uron countering the speed you're in the
whip then there's a few minor writing
flaws like yon's Fleet being able to
sneak up on them so easily and them kind
of just leaving Theon gr behind to live
how generous of yon to allow Theon the
opportunity to come back and save his
sister since the scene is 5 minutes
there's not a ton to talk about so yeah
on to number six I'm kind of cheating a
little bit but it's the battle of the
stepstones the video does say Game of
Thrones but I'll R in House of the
Dragon just to see where this battle
ranks in comparison to the others this
may seem relatively low but keep in mind
it's kind of hard to compete against
other battles that are much bigger and
longer because that's the main downside
to this battle in that it only lasts for
3 minutes excluding the Damon Rush which
going into that I still see a lot of
people knock it for having plot armor
and I still stand by the fact that it's
believable The Archers are very far away
trying to hit a Target in full Sprints
moving erratically and taking cover
occasionally so the fact that he is hit
with three arrows I might add since
people act like he doesn't get hit once
is fine with that out of the way I
really like the concept of Damon doing
an allout rush for his life it's infused
with high adrenaline that is severely
aided by the fact that there's a lot of
buildup to this moment rine jawadi also
helps the scene with his haunting score
that then explodes simultaneously with
the action I really love the progression
of this scene as he just barrels through
people and eviscerates them makes them
come across as such a badass and thus
makes him an even cooler character this
paired with the short battle right after
I think at least puts this in the middle
of my ranking there are some shots with
some wonk V effects like the blood
effects oddly looking bad but like usual
this battle hosts a lot of chaotic
energy it was cool though to see Lord
cor is a rip through people and gave the
action another fun perspective to follow
in the Mayhem at number five it's The
Spoils of War or the loot train attack
despite this battle taking place in a
rather Bad season of the show it still
manages to be pretty good it does have
its flaws obviously but it has some high
points for Action the initial breach of
Danny lighting up over a dozen people
with her dragon is one of the most
iconic moments in any battle sequence it
just hits you with an orgasmic Rush of
satisfaction because we've been waiting
for this kind of moment for six seasons
along with the execution being brutal
and practical I'm really happy that most
of the fire stuns weren't done digitally
and it makes the action so much more
authentic your jaw just hits the floor
because you've never seen anything on
this scale before then for the doth raki
the action has an interesting dynamic
because you see two completely different
styles of fighting Clash together in a
style that severely counters the other
as Robert Baratheon said we see some
cool variety like doth rocki shooting
arrows from horseback dual wielding arax
and their Superior dexterity and speed
as they take down multiple Lannister
soldiers before dying I've also kind of
skipped over it but the beginning of
this battle is an outstanding example of
perfect buildup it first interrupts a
normal dialogue scene with a distant
rumbling of horse Hooves to the Frantic
realization that they're going to get
rolled up on and they need to quickly
form a tangible defense to the reveal of
the massive Army coming over their
Horizon in which the heroes realize
they're screwed and then the even bigger
reveal of a dragon heading right for
them and it's about to turn into a blood
bath it's literally a perfect escalation
that gets you really hyped and reminds
me of the opening battle in the mummy
which I adored growing up also in the
buildup I love the Quick Cuts of
Lannister soldiers [__] their pants
it really allows you to sympathize with
them and how much fear they must be
feeling then from a technical standpoint
the battle is really impressive to me
because you have to simultaneously
juggle the ground Assa ass and the air
assault I think the creators found a
good balance in terms of presenting the
battle because it could have been very
incoherent it flows really well and even
the quick moments of action have more
time to breathe and aren't just quickly
thrown in to artificially make the edit
more chaotic then one last thing about
the action before going into the writing
side of things I think the wner with
Braun in the middle of the battlefield
was a great creative decision it
geniusly shows us this uninterrupted
hellish experience of dragon Warfare and
allows the audience to watch in horror
as to how brutal and crazy this must be
to go through like I'd even be scared to
go through this if I was fighting for
Daenerys so for the writing there are a
few niit piics like why didn't Danny do
a straight front down the defensive line
of Lannisters and why she destroyed the
food instead of capturing it but those
are pretty minor to me and the ending is
much worse in my opinion David and Dan
simultaneously wanted to keep Jamie
Lannister alive but they also wanted him
to be in the battle so getting him out
alive just fundamentally wouldn't make
sense and Braun tackling him into the
water and miraculously swimming an
entire Lake distance away is ridiculous
not to mention that jimie is wearing
full plated armor it sucks that David
and Dan couldn't come up with a better
way to get around it just thinking about
it now a significantly better change
would be to have jimie become
traumatized by watching his men getting
torched and have him simply run away
then he can deal with the burden of
abandoning his post and the Betrayal of
his men which eats him alive internally
this could also be a contributing factor
for him going north to fight for the
living because he wants to make amends
for his cowardice in the past not him
teleporting out of the battle so he can
artificially remain in the story so it's
pretty unfortunate that the ending to
this battle sucks because if that wasn't
the case then I'd put it higher onto
number four we have the battle of the
bastards now this may seem like heresy
putting what's regarded as the best
battle in the show at number four but
hear me out if it was just from the
perspective of action then this battle
would definitely be higher however you
have to also consider the story side of
things because that aspect drags this
battle down like jaam sinking to the
bottom of the lake there's sadly so many
aspects wrong with this like one of the
main ones being Sansa not telling Jon
about the veil which would have led to
an easy winning strategy of having much
higher numbers then another thing about
this that people don't consider is that
if Sansa confirmed earlier that she had
their support then most of the northern
houses who were hesitant to join most
likely would have which would increase
their chances of winning even more
instead David and Dan create a contrived
sense of an underdog Conflict for drama
the veil magically ared at the exact
moment of Jon's defeat and this may be a
nitpick but how would this large army
even be a surprise to the Bolton is
there no such thing anymore as Scouts
reporting on enemy movements like what
happened to the times in the earlier
Seasons where Tyran and Rob would get
constant reports on one another's armies
hell even Brien escorting Jaimie across
the country got spotted by a random
peasant but now armies are teleporting
around with literally no strategic or
geographical depth then there's your
obvious instances of plot armor of Jon
becoming a God and surviving dozens of
barrages and Cavalry Charges with this
critique I'm not saying that I want him
to die but instead I want him to sustain
some kind of injury because if he can
survive this then he ruined the realism
and sense of danger that were set in the
earlier Seasons there are some other
minor issues like one one basically
going into the war naked and with no
weapons the mostly idiotic military
strategy they're not really being any
character on the villain side fighting
that you care about within 2 minutes of
the battle there are massive piles of
body along with it being confusing as to
why it's so condensed when everyone is
spread out and people who don't
understand the concept of not running in
a straight line but hey now that we got
past that massive tsunami of dog [__] we
can finally appreciate the gorgeous
action on display because really
everything is firing on all cylinders
the cinematography is breathtaking and
establishes some of the most iconic
shots in the entire series of John
facing down in an entire cavalry charge
the ju opposing singles of JN and Ramsay
the POV of an arob barrage the insane
wner with clever ways of hiding Cuts in
the chaos and a brilliant top- down shot
of John reemerging as if he's being
reborn drawing genius parallels to
Danny's ending in season 3 fun fact this
moment wasn't actually planned and was
something that Miguel saach came up with
the night before shooting I also love
The Bleak Dow and cold color correction
for the overall episode looking
specifically at the action I think it's
a good combination of frantic Cuts with
quick action supplemented with Jon's
legendary wner it'd be nice if this
section of the battle was a bit longer
and we could see how JN was surviving
this chaos more but it's still great
nonetheless the overall production value
and what they were able to achieve with
an $1 million budget is insanely
impressive this has become a golden
standard of excellent V effects
integrated with practical elements if I
were to pause this Frame you probably
wouldn't be able to tell what's real and
fake but yeah the entire battle is
amazing from an action perspective and
it's really sad that it gets held back
by the shoddy writing at number three we
have hard home unlike battles before
this I honestly can't think of any big
flaws that deteriorate my enjoyment of
this it completely comes out of nowhere
and the pure excitement you feel from
being this surprised by a sudden battle
was truly a special experience it
absolutely floors you as all the
characters are left extremely vulnerable
Miguel saposnik perfectly captures the
panic and his area of people being
terrified and I think hiding the undead
behind the wall for a period of time
adds to the horror buildup that and it
acts as a good way to naturally slow
down the enemy so that they don't
immediately destroy our characters now
the action is predominantly quick cut
and fast-paced but I think that's much
more Justified because this isn't a
battle it's a massacre we do get some
occasional choreograph moments and in
particular I love the tracking shot of
Jon running through the battle and doing
a 360 Chop on a white we also get to see
one one absolutely obliterate his foes
for the first time which is amazing too
then besides most of this chaos we get a
duel between Jon and a white walker the
introduction of the White Walker in
particular was so badass and perfectly
framed along with it having thematic
significance of Fire and Ice but besides
this opening shot the White Walker
destroying this seemingly powerful
character makes you think Jon is screwed
for the fight and he pretty much is and
he kind of wins due to a lucky instance
in that he caught the White Walker off
guard since he was expecting his sword
to shatter
this paired with a handful of
magnificent moments like the undead
barreling off the cliff car SE getting
wrecked by white children Our Heroes
running together in unity with that
great Trio shot and the wall falling
down make this a consistently riveting
action setpiece not to mention the best
ending to any battle sequence on this
list being the iconic Resurrection scene
so yeah I came really close to putting
this battle at number two but I feel
like the next two have more to offer
than hard home for number two we have
blackwat before before going into the
action I want to point out how expertly
crafted the buildup to this battle was
because through the entire season
there's this constant dread in the air
that King's Landing will essentially be
helpless if Stanis decides to attack
them outright even leading right up to
the battle there's this nauseating
feeling of helplessness accentuated by
different characters then it's all
relieved by an immensely clever action
made by tyon and blowing up Sis's fleets
this adds to that euphoric Rush of
relieving that defeated mentality along
with this moment just being jawdropping
from how impressive the visuals and V
effects are it kind of reminds me of the
initial strafe that Daenerys does but
this moment has way more buildup and
story significance this moment leads to
a more triumphant feeling and throughout
the battle there's this EB and flow of
going from a winning and losing
mentality because even though this
explosion even the odds of it there's
still a daunting task in front of them
as they still have another half of s's
Army to repel this makes the battle
story-wise feel a lot more Dynamic and
unpredictable as to who you'll think
will win even though Taiwan is
technically on the way then for the
action there's technically not a lot of
it and this is probably a bit of a
budgetary issue but what they captured
was still good they infused it with
enough quantity of Carnage to capture
the essence of a crazy battle interpers
with the Hound absolutely obliterating
people I honestly could just watch that
for hours the highlight of this battle
to me however besides the explosion is
The Great Character work every major
character here essentially has an arc of
sorts between the Hound finally
defecting and Le leing Joffrey wimping
out and showing how much of a coward he
is inter Tyrion rising to the occasion
becoming the savior of King's Landing
essentially dismantling all the hateful
Notions people made towards him that
kind of emotional rush for the character
is so moving that you can't help but
feel incredibly excited there is some
more character work with Sansa and
Cersei but I honestly found that their
scenes hurt the pacing of the battle
their scenes are good but an unfortunate
side effect is the antsy feeling of
wanting to get back to the action it
kind of feels like these inter projected
scenes were more of a way to Pat out the
length of the battle because of the
relatively small budget then the scale
was still impressive with so many
wonderful wide shots of rushing the
beach and scaling the walls and hey a
character actually sustained some kind
of major injury and they didn't even
make a complete blunder like Jon Snow it
still pisses me off that he faces no
consequences for his mistake of falling
into Ramsay's trap but yeah the
Blackwater is an outstanding battle and
it's the first time in which we get to
witness an action scene on This
Magnificent scale finally at number one
we have the Watchers on the wall this
really shouldn't be a surprise because
this was also my favorite episode The
Watchers on the wall is perfect from
every single aspect whether it be scale
characters action choreography story
beats acting dialogue The Great setting
and cinematography it's all Flawless
from a story perspective the plotting
characters are incredibly investing
because this has been building up for
multiple Seasons there are some so much
emotional Stakes charged for each
character whether that be for sir aliser
desperately defending his home and not
wanting to be the first to fall to Wild
LS the conflicted nature of rose in that
she's angry at Jon but simultaneously
still loves him or Jon being torn
between killing these wildlings that
aren't the enemy it just feels like a
tragedy for him in that he has to defend
his brothers from people who should be
their allies so the story and characters
in this battle make every scene
thoroughly engaging because both sides
are considered as the good guys this
creates a lot more emotional and story
depth because the conflict isn't black
and white it's very complex and I like
it more than future battles that are
essentially just good versus evil then
of course the action is hard peaking
here like the iconic Warner of the
entire Courtyard and longer take dels
between different characters the
Watchers on the wall is also really the
first and only battle when you think
about it that has character dels where
we have torman versus sir Alistar and
Jon versus stir the only other battles
that has a character D is in the belt
between Jamie and euron which is just
yeah and then Battle of the bastards
where torman kills small John who really
didn't have any characterization and
John killing Ramsay which was just more
of a butchering I think character dos
creates a great dynamic in which you
have Stakes on both sides of the action
like you kind of wanting torment and
aliser to survive and for Jon to kill
stir instead of the generic mowing down
of random unnamed enemies it actually
creates an investment for this action
scene then there are so many iconic
moments like a giant impaling someone
with his bow and arrow dropping the
Scythe a giant riding a mammoth and the
boys coming together to take down a big
chongus it makes the battle consistently
exciting as it offers fresh and fun
moments you can really tell that the
budget is much higher here than the
Blackwater and makes me wonder how much
better that battle sequence would have
been with a bigger budget because this
battle just keeps you in a constant
state of Amazement because the
background action is always dialed up to
11 and there's so much VFX casually
being used to great effect then this is
something something that probably isn't
brought up a lot but I think the pacing
of this battle is spectacular because
most battles start and are essentially a
full Sprint to the Finish but the
Watchers on the wall feels like a
marathon there are a lot of Great
Character beats planted throughout this
battle like samel becoming more Brave
and even helping a scared pip Jon and
Sir alliser's delightful conversation
and different characters getting to take
charge which essentially gives some
cooldown time between certain action
beats that and the wor speat from Sir
aliser is [__] amazing and I just
adore his character also I have haven't
even touched on the tragic ending of Jon
losing Rose the battle ends with such a
dramatic gut punch and the convention
break in which the creators use slow
motion for the first time was genius it
links us into Jon's heads space as we
are solely focused on his misery amongst
the chaos surrounding him I can really
talk about this masterpiece of a battle
for like an hour and why it's so amazing
but yeah for the sake of your time I'll
end it here thank you for watching and
let me know in the comments where your
ranking would be I'm genuinely curious
because I know a lot of people's battle
tends to be the battle of the bastards
and I'm curious what you guys think and
by the way this video was voted on by my
patrons